well right now president biden is in  florida visiting the side of that deadly  building collapsed the death toll there  continuing to climb right now up to 18  remember this happened a week ago today  145 people are missing  the search for victims paused overnight  because of concerns about the stability  of the portion of that building that is  still standing  a specialist with the local fire  department spoke about the painstaking  search for people  in that debris we need to give them some  sort of closure  we need to find things for the family  members that are surviving that we can  bring to them  so they can feel some kind of sense of  nearness to their families  president biden also deploying federal  assistance to support state and local  responders there  commanders are hoping his visit will  bring some comfort  in the midst of just so much sadness